hello everyone thank you so much for
coming to listen to me talk I know
you've just had lunch and it's like
sleepy down time so I kind of feel like
this is a nice easy talk to ease us into
the afternoon hopefully uh so my name is
Joe Franti and I am a developer Advocate
at Spotify and this is my kitten puff
and I'm here to talk to you about stuff
that might be going on in your heads
right now the last few years have been
pretty hectic to say the least we've had
a pandemic we've had recession we've
seen redundancies throughout the
industry and you know not to mention
everything else that is going on in the
world right now so let's talk about
feelings and let's talk about mental
health and the things that we might
prefer not to talk about most of the
time and who am I to tell you this
stuff I'm obviously not a medical
professional but I am someone who has
gone through depression burnout anxiety
cptsd and I've had over a decade of
working with a therapist and I've done a
lot of personal research on this topic
because I'm a nerd and when you're nerd
you like to learn about things that
people are talking to you
about and as I've been researching and
as I've been talking at these Tech
events I've learned that there are a lot
of people out there who are feeling the
same things that I am and suffering from
similar issues to
me and I know things like stress and
mental health can be really difficult to
face and can be really difficult to talk
about so my hope for today is that I can
give you just some nuggets of thought to
take away with you so that you can make
your own Journeys make your own mental
health Journeys and and learn about
what's going on in your own heads and
not all of this talk is going to
resonate with you I kind of hope that
not everything in this talk does
resonate with you because we're going to
go into quite a lot of deep stuff but
what I do want to do is talk about the
hard things the things that are
sometimes considered taboo the things
that we find difficult to talk about in
a work
environment and I hope that you know if
this stuff doesn't affect you maybe you
can learn something to bring back for a
friend or a colleague who is suffering
from some of these things and I only
have an hour so I can't go into huge
depth on anything we're just going to
skim the surface of a lot of these
topics if you do want to chat to me
about any of these things you can get me
after the talk I'll be here today and
tomorrow or you can get me at this is
Joe Frank on the majority of the socials
whichever socials we're using these days
because we all need to get better at
talk talking about mental health openly
and
honestly and before we get started I'm
just going to give a brief content
warning here this talk does go over some
quite heavy and difficult topics we're
going to be talking about mental health
disordered thinking self harm and even
politics and if any of these topics are
too much for you or there's something
that you don't want to listen to right
now I will not be offended if you need
to
leave now at or at any time throughout
the talk the important thing is that you
keep yourself safe and happy and I
should also point out that the content
covered in this talk is my own opinion
and not necessarily that of my
employer so story time it's Monday
morning and you wake up and
already The Dread is starting to set in
it's another week of work getting up
feels difficult your body feels heavy
your eyes are heavy heavy your brain is
sluggish but you drag yourself out of
bed and get straight to your desk
because you missed your first alarm and
you have a meeting in two
minutes once the meeting is over you
have a long to-do list of stuff that you
need to get done throughout the day but
instead of writing down that to-do list
or even getting started on that to-do
list you instead check your emails you
read a few articles you scroll through
some social media you check in on SL
back and before you know it the entire
morning is gone and it's lunchtime and
you haven't actually got down to the
meat of your work yet so now the stress
is starting to set in so you eat a
packet sandwich at your desk instead of
going out and taking time
away and then your afternoon is
clobbered with meetings so you don't
actually get to start on your own work
until about 5:00 P p.m. when everyone
else has finally left you alone and you
try and cram an entire day's worth of
work into a few hours in the
evening by the time you finished you're
feeling even more
exhausted you'd hoped that maybe you'd
have time for a hobby or doing something
social this evening but you end up
having not quite enough energy to pick
anything up so you order some comfort
food and you watch some TV and you
decide to get an early night so that you
can feel less tired
tomorrow but as you climb into bed you
realize you didn't actually leave the
house today
and once your head hits the pillow all
of the things that you didn't manage to
get done today start to run through your
head you didn't manage to tidy the house
you forgot to reply to that email you
didn't quite finish off that piece of
work that you said that you get done
your boss said a weird thing in a
meeting and you're not quite sure what
they meant by it maybe they think that
you're
slacking your team members don't seem to
have these same struggles they seem to
get their work done I bet they were
super productive today I bet they had
lovely sociable evenings with their
friends so to quiet in this onslaught of
horribleness that comes as soon as your
head hits the pillow you take your phone
out and you start to play a Mindless
game or you scroll social media until
the small hours in the morning when you
finally fall asleep through actual
exhaustion and you realize as you do
that you're going to be so tired in the
morning
and come the weekend you think great I
can finally relax but your brain doesn't
let you you're suddenly stressed about
all the things that you didn't manage to
get done during the week you are so
tired that you don't wake up until
midday on Saturday and then you feel
like you need to be productive because
you've wasted half the day you've wasted
a quarter of your entire
weekend why don't you have enough
energy why don't you
why aren't you able to do the things
that you want to do now you feel like
you need to be productive but all you
want to do is rest but when you do try
to rest you feel guilty about the fact
that you're resting and not doing
something productive so you cancel any
of the fun things that you had planned
to do to try and conserve energy for the
week coming and you guilt yourself over
not having done enough and even though
you are resting every second of that
rest your brain is telling you why
aren't you doing so something you could
be doing more I bet other people are
doing more fun things and you just feel
stressed and tired and achy and nauseous
and you wonder whether this is ever
going to get any
better and if any of that was relatable
I'm going to talk through some of the
factors and the feelings that cause us
to think like this so this is your
autonomic nervous system this is a
system in your body that you don't
consciously control but it regulates
Ates the involuntary physiological
processes such as your heart rate your
respiration your blood pressure your
digestion and uh hormone release and
it's this system that reacts when you're
under a physical threat the autonomic
nervous system produces your fight ORF
flight response it helps you to be ready
if you need to run away from
danger and when you're under stress the
autonomic nervous system kicks in and
sends a bunch of messages around the
body so it gets adrenaline around the
body and cortisol and oxygen to the
places where they need to be and this
can cause physical symptoms such
as uh increased heart rate uh shortness
of breath sometimes shakiness nausea
stomach
pain and if you're feeling stress or
anxiety over a prolonged period of time
it means that your autonomic nervous
system is constantly being activated
it's constantly sending those stress
hormones throughout your body it's
constantly increasing your heart rate
it's constantly making your muscles
ready to spring into
action and your body is sort of being
flooded with These Warnings even when
the situation isn't life or death and
the problem with this prolonged stress
and this prolonged activation of your
nervous system is that your nervous
system starts to become easier to
trigger and you you start to become more
frequently flooded with these physical
symptoms and this can actually take a
massive toll on not only your mental
health but also your physical health and
you know in today's world with the
pandemic and Eep economic collapse uh
house prices soaring tech industry in
turmoil a lot of us will be feeling
these physical symptoms without
realizing what's actually causing them
and how much the underlying stress can
affect us it's an incredibly stressful
time to be alive at the moment there's
stress about what our lives are
like stress about whether or not we're
going to get the virus whether we're
going to lose our jobs and many of us
are in this sort of constant state of
heightened anxiety and an activated
nervous
system so I'm going to go through an
alphabet of the things that we might be
feeling and let's start at a for anxiety
now anxiety is a completely normal and
natural part of life it is completely
usual and acceptable to feel anxiety
when you're in a an new experience or
something where there might be a bit of
stress like doing a job interview or
doing public speaking and it's a normal
reaction to a tough or new situation and
the physical symptoms of anxiety that we
might see are rapid breathing or
increased heart rate light headedness
dizziness you might start to get like
some stomach
interestingness uh chest pain
fatigue insomnia headaches and in the
short term anxiety you know it increases
your heart rate it gets blood flow to
your brain and it's a very physical
response which helps you to get through
an intense situation but anxiety becomes
a problem when it becomes excessive or
it becomes long-term
your poor nervous system is in this
constant state of activation giving your
body messages that you're in danger a
long-term anxiety can cause things like
panic attacks because your brain is
constantly releasing the stress hormone
it can cause dizziness and it can
actually cause
depression this constantly increased
level of adrenaline and cortisol in your
body can also lead to some fun physical
symptoms like muscle aches uh muscle
spasms it can have issues for your
immune system so you end up getting ill
more often it can lead to IBS so your
stomach is constantly in pain anxiety
can stop you from doing the very things
that would actually help to reduce your
anxiety like socializing or trying new
things or going outside into the
sunlight but the good news is that there
are a bunch of things that we can do to
reduce
anxiety but they will all be very
different depending on the
individual so if you feel yourself in a
state of anxiety these are some helpful
coping
strategies the first and most important
thing is to remember to breathe when
you're in that sort of spiral The Well
of anxiety you will find yourself
breathing very quickly and shallowly so
remember first to take deep slow
steadying breaths I have an app on my
watch that actually will buzz in time
for me to take breaths if you don't have
that that um you can just do counting so
breathe in slowly and deeply counting to
seven and you want to breathe from your
stomach so really get the breath all the
way through your lungs breathe in for
seven hold for seven and exhale slowly
pushing with your stomach again all the
way for seven and do this for a few
minutes until you start to feel your
heart rate slow back down and once you
get into that state where you're being a
bit more mind and a bit less panicky
then you can start to use grounding
techniques which will help you feel less
anxious and again these are all going to
be very different for the
individual based
on WE base the grounding techniques on
your senses so you want to look listen
smell touch and taste so maybe look into
the distance look away from your screen
look at something that you find calming
if you've got a nice view out your
window looking at nature can really help
uh listen to sounds that you find
soothing either music or nature sounds
something that's going to calm you down
smelling something pleasant like a nice
herbal tea or a a candle or a perfume
something that you find Pleasant
touching something soft like a a pet or
a cuddly toy or even just a soft scarf
can really help to ground you or I find
fidget toys really help as well if I'm
sort of in that anxious state it helps
me direct the nerves into
something and finally tasting something
nice so a cool glass of water or a cup
of caffeine free tea or eating some
fruit can all help to take you out of
that stress State and back into a more
mindful moment where you're more in
touch with what is actually happening in
your body and learning your own self
soothing techniques is absolutely vital
because anxiety and panic attacks can
leave you absolutely tired stressed and
burnt
out and burnout is a state of physical
and emotional exhaustion it happens when
you experience long-term stress or
you've been physically or emotionally
drained for a long period of time and
the common signs of burnout include
things like feeling tired or drained all
the time feeling helpless or trapped all
the time feeling like you're defeated
before you've even started something
feeling detached and alone like no one's
there to help you having a very cynical
mindset or feeling a lot of
self-doubt procrastinating frequently or
feeling overwhelmed frequently and
burnout can cause your brain to feel
kind of foggy and uncooperative and it
happens when you keep pushing and
pushing and continuing through stress
and not allowing yourself any recovery
time since lockdown and increased things
like working from home the lines between
our work and our home life have really
blurred and we're sometimes not very
good at switching off at the end of the
work
day and this means that our even things
like social interaction and social
environments have changed we're not
getting those nice breaks throughout the
day where we can you know stop and talk
to colleagues and get a cup of
tea and it just makes it more difficult
to switch off because we feel like our
work and our home environment are sort
of mixing and we're checking our emails
at midnight and we're seeing slack
notifications coming from our colleagues
at all times and when we wake up in the
morning the first thing we do is check
our phone and check our email and our
body has no time to not be thinking
about work no time to be
relaxing we're all trying to be the
model employee but by doing so we're
actually taking ourselves closer to
burnout and closer to the point where we
can't actually get any work down at all
and along with the brain fog and the
exhaustion and the overwhelm burnout is
really dangerous it can lead to
depression and it can lead to suicidal
ideation because you feel so helpless
you feel like there's nothing left to be
done and you need to take that final
step and many people that I've spoken to
who have gone through burnout talk about
just wishing that everything would just
stop and burnout isn't something that
goes away on its own like this is not
something that you should take
lightly it can actually worsen if you
don't address the underlying issues that
are causing it if you ignore the signs
of burnout it can cause harm to your
physical and your mental health it can
lead to chronic fatigue to immune system
issues an a memory loss if you push past
your limits it isn't something that you
can just take a holiday from it will
really really affect your
body but burnout can be avoided by just
putting a little bit of self-care into
our daily routine so even if you are
working long hours or you're studying or
you're taking care of young children
remember just to sprinkle a little bit
of view time a little bit of joy into
your day it's is absolutely essential to
replenish your emotional energy and your
physical energy and it's actually going
to help you to
focus so if you're having trouble
squeezing these kinds of things into
your
day uh try
and use a weekly calendar to assess how
it is that you're actually spending your
time so you can do this you know on a
piece of paper or in a spreadsheet or in
an app and block out maybe every two
hours of each day
and just write down what it is that
you're doing how you're feeling about
what it is that you're doing and uh
maybe give it a scale so from 1 to 10
where 10 equals I'm I'm completely happy
and this is brilliant and I love what
I'm doing a one equals I'm drained I
hate this I never want to do this again
and then also give it a scale of how
valuable you think that activity is so
did I really need to do this and it was
draining but it needed to get done or I
did need to do this and it was draining
and maybe I can look at how I can get
rid of this in the future and it'll help
you find opportunities for where you can
limit your exposure to tasks that are
massively
draining and it'll help you assess the
things that put you in a negative mood
versus put you in a positive mood and
help you increase your investment in the
things that make you
happy stress is just something that
happens it's it's an unavoidable part of
life but burnout should be preventable
and as much as it pains me to say and
like people told me this throughout my
entire life and I was like yeah
whatever these five things will make a
real difference
so exercise I hate to say it but
exercise makes a massive
difference it helps you to connect with
your body and I'm not talking about you
know going and doing an hourong workout
at the gym it can be you know a gentle
walk or just doing some stretching
anything that makes you a little bit
more mindful of how your muscles are
feeling how your body is feeling
generally next try and eat well eating a
healthy diet balanced diet with a good
amount of slow release carbohydrates
good fats and vitamins is actually it's
a natural
anti-depressant it will actually
help uh give your body the nutrients
that it needs and it can give you a mood
boost practice good sleeping habits if
you can try and get in a relaxing time
before bed so instead of going straight
from I'm using my laptop to I'm now in
bed or I'm using my phone to I'm now in
bed have some time away from your screen
have some time where you can wind down
before your head hits the
pillow and don't forget to ask for help
during stressful times it can feel
really difficult to reach out to other
people um and ask for assistance just
feels like you're being a burden on
somebody but you're not uh consider
implementing a self-care checkin with a
friend um just so that you can take care
of each other in difficult times you
know if you're having a stressful day
just be able to message them and say
like H I had a crap time today uh and
then they can know to check in on you
over the next few days just to make sure
that your mental health isn't suffering
too
much and the tech industry has seen so
so many cases of burnout I bet every
single person in this room has either
felt burnout at some point or knows
someone who is burnt
out we have this dangerous tendency to
blur the lines between our jobs and our
lives because we love what we do and you
know we all think of ourselves as nerds
and we all think of ourselves as
enthusiastic we all constantly want to
know everything to be the smartest
person in the room and we're constantly
comparing ourselves to these experts
that we see on stage and that we read in
articles and we're constantly thinking
like I'm not doing as well as them I
need to keep
going but it's really no surprise when
we're acting like this we're basically
burning the candle at both ends and then
we're sort of caught unawares when it
meets in the middle and we've got
nothing left to
give and there re there is another
reason why a lot of us are burning out
and that's not personal
Pride it is this thing here
capitalism so if we look at it up in
Wikipedia capitalism is an economic and
political system in which a country's
trade and Industry are controlled by
private owners for
profit and the essential feature of
capitalism is to make profit and so in
under capitalism we have assets such as
materials and factories and land that is
privately owned and labor is then
purchased in order to add value to these
assets and to produce products which are
then sold to get more capital and of
course the people who are doing the
labor are rewarded we're all paid to do
our work but in order for profit to come
out of the end the labor kind of has to
be undervalued it has to be paid less
than it is worth or the capitalists and
the business owners wouldn't be making a
profit out the
end and this is a really difficult topic
to talk about in such a short short
amount of time and of course I'm going
to do a mediocre job but here we go the
majority of us are those laborers in the
middle we're working to create profit
for a business owner somewhere and I
realize we work in Tech we're all very
well paid that's great we're very well
off we're using our skills and our
creativity and our drive and our energy
to try and make better things and we
tend to love what we do and we want to
make improvements to the world we want
to make the world a better place but the
thing is that the people at the top the
investors and the business
owners especially for those of us who
are working in very large corporations
aren't so interested in making the world
a better place they're more interested
in making a profit and this is one of
the major forces that is causing
burnout we have this sort of balance of
intentions of the people who want to do
good stuff and build cool things and the
people who just want to make a profit
out at the end of it and we're now
living in a world where we're no longer
able
to earn the capital that is required to
potentially buy a house or to live a
comfortable life and for some people you
know they can't even afford food and
heating and we're taught that we should
just keep working harder we should keep
chasing that
dollar and it's this hustle culture that
we're living through that is lied to us
about how if we just keep working hard
enough we'll be able to reach that point
where we're comfortable if we go above
and beyond then we can reach that point
of comfort but the truth is for the
majority of us that's not possible it
can't be possible or the 1% wouldn't
exist there have to be people who are
taken advantage of in order for others
to become incredibly
wealthy and we start hearing this lie
from when we're very young we when we're
in school we're told that we need to
constantly be achieving we need to get
good grades and then your teacher and
your parents convince you that you need
to go straight to University and get the
best education that you can so you can
get the best job that you possibly can
and when you finally get that job you
want to perform as well as you possibly
can so that your boss tells you that you
did a good job
we are sort of trained to want praise
and to be seen as the best at what we
do and I hate to generalize but I'm
going to guess that a lot of us in this
room were the little kid who was you
know we were top of the class we were
the one who desperately wanted to be you
know first in all the
tests uh we wanted to get the teachers
praise and we learned to base ourselves
selfworth on how capable we were of
continuing to be the best being at the
top of the class getting the most praise
we could possibly could which means that
we feel like we need to be constantly
working we need to be constantly
productive we need to constantly be
showing what we're doing so that other
people tell us that we're doing okay and
we're doing a good job we constantly
need that external
validation and it just leads you to
working harder than you
really are paid to do you're giving your
time and your energy and your physical
and mental health to these jobs where
you're only paid to work they don't want
your entire life force they just want
you to do a job but we feel like we need
to give everything and I'm afraid I
don't have a huge amount of advice on
how to avoid
capitalism if you notice your fellow
employees working overtime giving too
much getting incredibly stressed please
have a word with them uh give to
Charities help folks from Minority
backgrounds help make sure that everyone
in your team is paid a fair wage uh vote
next time there's an election I really I
yeah capitalis capitalism is as
capitalism
does but this leads me on to our next
letter anxiety and burnout and overwork
amongst other things can have a massive
impact on your mental wellbeing and
record numbers of people at the moment
are feeling poor mental health according
to the World Health Organization it's
globally estimated that around 5% of
adults are suffering from
depression and depression is
characterized by a feeling of persistent
sadness a lack of interest in things
that you previously enjoyed a lack of
feeling of pleasure or Pride or
achievement and just a lack of
connection with the people who are
around you and depression can really
drain your cognitive function um a good
prediction of depression is
self-criticism so if you have that
little nasty voice in the back of your
head that tells you you're not good
enough that
you're there's no way that you could
possibly compare to people around you
that you shouldn't even try and
self-criticism and low self-esteem can
be caused by depression they can be
caused by burnout they can be caused by
imposter syndrome they can be caused by
perfectionism which I'll talk about
later and all of these are really
prevalent in people who work in the tech
industry worsening matters being
self-critical not only leads to
depressive symptoms but then those
depressive symptoms can make yourself
criticism worse and we get this fun
horrible
cycle and depression is a real illness
and it should be treated with as much
respect as we would treat for example a
broken leg and the good news is that
help is available again I know it's easy
to say but there are things that you can
do to help yourself out of a depressive
episode getting exercise getting
Outdoors eating well sleeping these
things all actually work and I know
everybody tells us this and it's very
easy to say and less easy to do but they
really do make a big
difference one of the best ways to get
to know the things that help you out of
a depressive episode is to do talking
therapy and I will talk a little bit
deeper about this later but getting a
therapist can feel like a really big
step and it can feel like you know
you're being um self-indulgent by
getting a therapist for yourself
and like I get it it took me 2 years
when a friend said to me maybe you
should get therapy for me to go oh no
way I do actually need therapy at first
I was just like what are you talking
about and I need therapy like I get it
it's difficult but once you have spoken
to a therapist uh you can decide
together the things that might help you
out one of those things might be
medication with both therapy and
medication you don't have to take the
first thing that is offered to you you
can speak to multiple different
therapists and find the one that works
for you you can try multiple different
medications and try the one that works
for you and I would like to reiterate
there is absolutely no shame in seeking
any of these options and there should be
no shame in talking about it with your
colleagues with your
friends and just making this a easier
thing for us to talk about and an easier
thing for us to recognize in other the
people okay so this was all quite heavy
going we're going to take a little
mental uh breather um so e is for emu uh
so let's watch Emanuel the
emua and Richard those are R and those
are actually more similar to Emanuel
Emanuel don't do it Emanuel do not do it
Emanuel Emanuel Todd Lopez
Emmanuel
that brings me great joy in my soul that
you
listened I love you you are a good
boy come here come show them how big you
are everybody thinks you and Humpty are
the same type of cow this is a Emanuel
do not do it Emanuel don't do it
Emanuel don't do it I'm trying to
educate people right now
okay can you just stop tall okay so euu
are flightless birds and uh if they are
like Emanuel they also kind of up for a
fight which leads me on to our next
topic uh F is for a fight of flight um
and the fight oflight response is the
body's natural physiological reaction to
a stressful environment uh to a
frightening or a dangerous event and
it's activated by your perception of a
threat so what it does is it very
quickly activates that autonomic nervous
system into releasing the hormones and
preparing your body to either run away
from the threat or to take it head
on and it's a hold over from you know
ancient ancestors who had to choose you
know if they're faced by like a
saber-tooth tiger do I stay or do I
run uh and it gives your body you you
know that little bit of extra energy
boost to keep you Nimble and strong and
focused and we call these when this
happens we say that you're in a state of
activation or you're in a state of high
arousal you're your blood is pumping
you're breathing fast you're getting a
lot of oxygen to your muscles and many
of the high arisal situations that we
face in Modern Life are nothing like
facing a
uh it could be something like a
difficult meeting or a salary discussion
but the problem comes again when we're
talking about a long-term state of
activation long-term or repeated stress
can cause our nervous system to be in
constant activation a constant fight or
flight mode and it can be absolutely
exhausting to live with imagine your
body's constantly telling you you're in
danger like it's just so tiring and it
gets to the point where even small
stresses like having to decide what
you're having for dinner that night or
uh
deciding where you want to go that
evening can become emotionally
overwhelming because your body's like
you're in danger and you're like I just
need to decide whether I want Burger or
pizza and psychologists have come to
realize that our bodies don't only
choose fight or flight mode there's
actually two other options as well which
are a lot less spoken about so I don't
know if you've heard of the freeze or
for options as well so not only can
stress give you the opportunity to fight
or to run away it can actually just
cause you to freeze in very high stress
environments if you've ever come out of
an interview and been unable to remember
what on Earth it was that you just said
in that interview that could be a freeze
response it's your body just completely
shutting down and going into automatic
mode shutting down your active thinking
and losing yourself in uh Doom scrolling
or in playing a silly game is also a
freeze response it's I don't know how to
deal with this I'm not going to deal
with this I'm just going to shut down
and we're going to have no no input is a
loud only silly
game and if you ever find yourself
procrastinating over a task that you
know that you need to get done that's
also a freeze response you can't do
badly at the task if you never start it
your body is shutting down rather than
doing the thing that it doesn't want to
do super helpful thanks brain and
getting out of a freeze State can be
really tough it requires a lot of
self-kindness and it requires really
understanding what is happening in your
body you need to
recognize okay I'm in a freeze state I'm
I'm shutting down I'm curling up I'm I'm
going to a place where I don't my brain
doesn't want to do anything how can I
break W up the tasks that I don't want
to do into smaller manageable tasks how
can I vocalize to somebody that I need
their help to get me out of this state
and again this is absolutely something
that you can work on with a therapist
highly
recommend and so the other thing is
foring and foring is a strategy that we
subconsciously learn to get out of
trouble and it can quite often come as
Trauma from interacting with a difficult
person at a young age it's the thing
that we do when we bend over backwards
to please somebody and it I'm not
talking about you know being nice or
being considerate I'm talking about
putting everybody else's needs before
your own needs it's an over niess and it
stems from us learning that we have
everybody has to Like Us in order for us
to survive in order for us to get the
nurturing that we need so if if you find
yourself are you the person that maybe
apologizes for everything have you ever
walked into a room and said sorry to the
people in the room and they're like what
are you apologizing for you know
existing uh or if you're the person that
um gets made to take notes in a meeting
for example and you just sit there you
go yeah okay I can do that or if anybody
needs anything done you're the person
who says oh yeah I can totally do that
everybody I'm happy to take on all these
extra responsibilities as long as
everybody likes me and then I'll be safe
uh one of the things that I do is at the
end of video calls I go I turn into this
like ridiculous person who's like thanks
bye everyone you're amazing thank you so
much oh this has been brilliant thanks
and I'm just like where is this person
coming from and the problem with this
phone response is that you rarely put
your own needs first and you have a
tendency to attract people who can see
what you're doing and know that they can
take advantage of that and make you do
extra work for
them and if you do find yourself giving
these sort of fa
responses the thing that you need to
learn to do is to say no more
regularly
uh if somebody asks you to do something
it's totally fine for you to say no they
might be disappointed in the moment but
they're not going to hate
you uh understand that conflict is
sometimes unavoidable is sometimes
necessary it's just going to get you
past a difficult phase it's not going to
make everybody hate you and try and
learn to use a different phrase other
than sorry so instead of apologizing for
existing or being in a space say uh
thank you so instead of I'm sorry I'm
late or I'm sorry for taking your time
say thank you for waiting for me or
thank you for coming to this
meeting
let's move on to G so I don't want to
have to tell you to touch grass but um
please everybody touch grass uh spending
time outside in nature makes such a huge
difference to your mental health um
there was some research done in
hospitals and schools that found having
just one plant in your room and looking
at that plant can have a massive impact
on how much stress you feel and some
researchers in Australia did this
amazing uh study where they had a bunch
of students engage in a really dull
repetitive task they just had to press a
key when a certain number flashed up on
the screen and the students
who before doing this task were Sat by a
window looking out on a garden for 40
seconds made significantly fewer
mistakes than the students who were sat
at a window looking out at a concrete
roof just looking at nature can have a
massive impact on how relaxed our brain
feels and how capable we are of
processing so if you can't touch grass
at least look at a
leaf and with many of us working from
home we're not getting outside as much
as we can so try and
schedule time to actually get outside
and you know go for a walk look into the
distance try and schedule in time for
socializing that isn't what work related
so that we can actually take a break and
have that social interaction that
increases that sort of dopamine in our
minds without mindlessly scrolling
social
media a lot of people who are working
from home report that they feel
massively
isolated and another thing that a really
interesting study that I found said that
we're all starting to get stressed by
seeing our own faces so much because
when you're in a video call who do you
look at in the video call you have a
tendency to look at your own face right
and a lot of us then especially those of
us who have low self-esteem find
ourselves judging ourselves and judging
our own faces because we're staring at
them for hours and a
day so make sure that you are giving
yourself away from screen time that
you're giving yourself Pleasant social
time and you're giving your brain just a
chance to chill out a little bit
make sure when you're working from home
that you're setting boundaries as much
as possible and I realize this is really
difficult and it's something we're all
still learning to understand um but make
sure that you have work hours and home
hours and when you're not working you're
putting your phone away you're putting
your email away you're turning off your
slack notifications you're not getting
your brain back into that stress place
when you're supposed to be rela
relaxing make sure that you've got a
really great workstation set up you've
got a comfortable chair your desk is the
right height keeping your body in a
comfortable and healthy place makes a
huge difference take regular breaks as I
mentioned look at a leaf like half a
window nearby or a plant or
something uh remember to have some sort
of social connection with your
colleagues and try not to check your
work email just before you go to bed or
first thing when you wake up give your
brain a little bit of relaxing time a
little bit of Separation time so that
you can wind down in the evening and
wind back up in the morning by checking
your work email first thing in the
morning you're jumping your autonomic
nervous system back into stress time you
know we've just woken up and now it's
time to already be thinking about what
we're doing like no go look outside have
some nice breakfast have a cup of tea
chill out then check your work
email part of the reason why a lot of us
are you know doing all this working over
time we're checking our work email we're
checking slack all the time is because
we want to feel like we're good enough
and we want to show our colleagues that
we're working as hard as we possibly can
we're the best one that we can possibly
be because of this thing called imposter
syndrome an impostor syndrome makes you
feel like you're a fraud that by dumb
luck you've ended up in the same place
as people who are worthy and that you
don't actually deserve to be where you
are and this is an incredibly Universal
feeling like I'm going to make the
assumption that everyone in this room
has felt imposter syndrome at some point
in their
lives people like yourselves who are
highly skilled highly
intelligent tend to think that our
colleagues are also highly skilled and
highly intelligent and this can lead us
to judge ourselves against them but to
do so really unfairly and
harshly and this judgment can cause you
to see the things that you've achieved
but believe that you don't deserve them
that the qualifications and the
accolades that you have earned are in
some way not as good as the ones that
your colleagues have earned or that you
got them because of luck or you got them
because of you know somebody else
helping you that it wasn't just you who
managed to do
it and it can be coupled with the belief
that you know this acol Accolade that
you got somehow isn't it's not worth
anything because you got it it must be
easy it's not praiseworthy
anymore have you ever worked on a
project and felt like you know when you
finally completed it it wasn't good
enough or
that it wasn't enough to prove to
yourself that you deserve to be
there or that someone made a mistake in
awarding an Accolade or a qualification
to you or that what you did was just
luck and it wasn't actually earned
imposter syndrome doesn't let you feel
any Pride or joy in any of your
achievements because it constantly wants
you to be working towards the next thing
and the next
thing and the more that I've spoken to
people who work in the tech industry
about imposter syndrome the more I have
learned how completely Universal this
feeling is something fishy is going on
if you feel like you're not worthy but
also the person sitting next to you
feels like they're not worthy and you
deserve to to be there and the person
sitting next to them feels like they're
not worthy and you deserve to be there
you know there's there's some sort of
logical fallacy going on here and
talking talking with others about
impostor syndrome and how much we feel
this Universal feeling can really help
us to be a little bit more realistic
about whether or not we deserve to be
here and whether or not the things that
we've done are worthy whenever I'm
worrying that everyone in the room knows
more than I do about something or that I
don't belong I like to call think of
this thing that I call Shing there
impostor syndrome it's this this kind of
impostor syndrome double think it's
cognitive dissonance so I have convinced
myself that all of my peers are far
better than me all of my peers are more
intelligent than I am all of my peers
are more accomplished than I am and I
don't deserve to be here I don't know
anything I'm never going to amount to
anything and yet my peers are also so
gullible so stupid that clever me has
tricked them into believing that I
belong amongst
them my logic is fallible and therefore
likely so is my disbelief in myself
these two things cannot exist at the
same
time okay so we've got what 10 minutes
left
we would be here all day if I triy to do
every single letter of the alphabet so
let's have another cute break instead
here is a video of a tiny goat jumping
off a
log get up
here did you get
it come
on he's having the time of his life
get up
here so let's jump from J to p uh and
this is one of my favorite things to
talk about
perfectionism uh I'm pretty certain that
a bunch of you have all felt some
perfectionist Tendencies at some point
uh if we look it up perfectionism is a
personality trait that is characterized
by a person striving for flawlessness
setting high performance standards and
and having critical
self-evaluation along with concerns
regarding others evaluations which if I
was an employer I'd be like sounds
pretty great actually I want to hire
someone who strives for flawlessness who
sets high performance standards and
cares about others evaluations they
sound like the kind of person that I
want to work
with but
imagine that you're that person you are
constantly striving for perfection and
I'm not talking Excellence I'm not
talking Brilliance I'm talking actual
Perfection you cannot help but set
yourself up to fail not many people
achieve Perfection perfectionism is
actually a blocker to achievement
perfectionists have a tendency to
measure our own self-worth on how
capable we are of achieving
Perfection and when we don't which is
most likely because as I say most people
don't achieve perfection we can be
really harsh on ourselves the problem is
that our belief is that if we can't
achieve Perfection we are bad people
rather than we've done a bad job
our uh performance is intertwined with
our sense of self when we don't succeed
we don't just feel disappointed in how
we did we feel disappointed in who we
are as a person we feel
shame and perfectionists have a tendency
to engage in something called cat
catastrophic thinking or you might hear
it called black and white thinking where
everything becomes either perfect or
completely terrible disaster and work
that most people would say is good
enough or even work that most people
would say is brilliant it's not perfect
and therefore it's terrible therefore
it's a complete
disaster and the tech industry and
capitalism love it when we strive for
Perfection they want us to be constantly
building as much as we possibly can
learning as much as we possibly can uh
striving to become even better striving
to earn more money so that then we can
spend it on becoming even
better and perfectionist employees will
pressure themselves into burnout into
paralysis into depression all while
continuing to hand in actually really
great
work but never daring to ask for help
because asking for help would be proving
that they can't be perfect if somebody
else has to help me then I'm not
perfect and like those with impostor
Syndrome perfectionists have a tendency
to disregard their own achievements
because they're you can never achieve
Perfection it's never good enough so as
soon as they achieve something they're
instantly like well that didn't work so
next thing and next thing and next thing
and of course it's going to lead to burn
out is going to lead to overwork it's an
absolutely unsustainable and unhappy way
to
be moving on to Q uh I don't know if
you've heard of quiet quitting this is a
trend that sort of happened on Tik Tok a
year or so ago and half of the trend was
employers worrying that remote workers
weren't putting in the outers and half
of it was folks who are on minimum wage
empowering the M themselves and their
colleagues to resist hustle
culture and if we boil it all down quiet
quitting is when an employee puts in no
more effort to their job than they are
paid to
do it's about resisting the go over and
above mentality quiet
quitting it's not a thing it's not
actually a thing although the media
would like us to believe that it's a
thing it is literally just setting
healthy boundaries and doing the amount
of work that is expected of you and not
working yourself into an early
grave and with the economy in its
current state a lot of us haven't seen a
pay rise in a while the with inflation
and the cost of living increasing
constantly it's kind of understandable
why employees might be just you know
reeling it back a bit thinking about how
much effort they're putting into their
jobs and I'm not talking about you
know doing a rubbish job I'm talking
about continuing to do your job as
excellently as you always would but
making sure that you're setting those
boundaries so not checking your work
email in the middle of the night not
checking it as soon as you get up in the
morning and recognizing that a lot of
these what we call citizenship behaviors
are actually worthy and important so
things like staying late or coming in
early or helping to organize work
socials or attending non-mandatory
meetings these are all things that are
actually worthy and worthwhile and
should be considered praiseworthy and
these are things that you should be
talking about talking with about talking
with your manager about doing so making
sure that if you are doing these things
if you are coming in early if you're
working late if you're organizing work
socials people know that you're doing
this so that you can get get the praise
for
it it's also worth mentioning that for
women for people of color and for
immigrants it's often a luxury to not
take on these citizenship
behaviors minorities in Tech and those
who require a Visa often have to do this
extra emotional labor and this extra
manual labor in order to be recognized
as working at the same level as their
peers leaving work on time not replying
to your emails at of hours maintaining a
healthy work life balance is not quiet
quitting it's just taking care of
yourself going above and beyond should
be exactly that it should be a thing
that you do occasionally when necessary
it shouldn't be the expected Behavior it
cannot be above and
beyond if it's what's expected of you
that's just too much
work R is for rest you are allowed to
rest please rest rest is really
important to reduce the stress levels to
help your body recover physically to
help your mind to recover when you rest
you will find that your concentration
level after resting is actually greatly
improved and getting good rest can
sometimes require discipline and
planning which feels ridiculous but it
really
does you have to actually book in time
for yourself and say this is my resting
time say no to people who are going to
try and take that time away from you
avoid filling that time with chores or
other things that you need to get done
and don't spend the entire of your rest
time staring at your screen or staring
at a TV try and actually take some time
with yourself to process your day and
just mentally go through you know how
you're feeling and how your body's
feeling and just check in with
yourself to add to the message of
getting good rest sleep is equally
important sleep is essential to help
your body function uh your immune system
your metabolism your memory your
attention are all improved by getting a
good night's sleep and adults need
between seven and nine hours of sleep
generally with men needing a bit less
than women uh
scientifically so in order to establish
a better sleep routine I
spoke about some of these briefly
earlier um but try and find a sensible
bedtime and stick to it even on the
weekends uh getting some exercise
throughout the day will help you feel
sleepy it will help you actually sleep
better try and abstain from things like
caffeine and alcohol just before bed
check your sleep environment like is it
a pleasant place is your bed somewhere
where you actually want to be like have
you got a nice mattress have you
invested Ed in some nice bed sheets and
some nice pillows like make it a place
where you actually want to be and you
will find yourself sleeping better and
sleeping
longer Implement a no screen time before
bed like 20 minutes before bed put the
phone down put it in drawer something
like that where you won't be tempted to
pick it up and that's the time where
you're going to take to process how the
day went how you're feeling about it so
that by the time you actually close your
eyes on your pillow you've done that
processing and your brain won't suddenly
fire
up and if you find yourself with
struggling with switching off and
struggling with thoughts of the day I
absolutely cannot recommend enough
getting yourself some talking therapy it
is the best thing that you could
possibly do for yourself it is the one
if there's one thing that you take away
from this entire talk it is this please
get therapy it's like a massage for your
brain um there's a whole bunch of
different different ways that you can do
this there's talking therapy there's
counseling there's a bunch of
apps um in the UK at least you can get
therapy on the NHS but it's a slow
process or you can talk to private
therapists like I mentioned before you
do not have to go with the first
therapist that you find do some research
into the therapists who specialize in
the things that you want to talk about
book meetings with a few different ones
and just get to know them they expect
you to do this this is completely
normal um and you may well find that
your employer offers something like
counseling or uh some sort of uh health
insurance that'll help so it's very
worth speaking to your manager or your
HR person to see if they support
this okay that was a lot I really hope
that I haven't overloaded you all what I
I hope is that I've planted some seeds
for you to ponder and think about over
the next few days and weeks and months
and like I said not all of this was
going to resonate but I hope that it
gives you just some food for
thought I'm always up for chatting uh
like I said you can get me at this is
Joe Frank on the majority of the socials
on threads masteron
X Blue Sky you name it I'm there
please look after yourselves please look
after your friends and your colleagues
and you know everyone in the tech
industry we are in some interesting
times at the moment and it is imperative
that we carve out moments for ourselves
to feel happy and joyful and thank you
all so much for listening I hope you
have a fantastic rest of the day and uh
a good evening and a good conference
thank
you